it's not every day that you look out the
window and see a herd of wild elephants
walking down the street
but that was what locals saw in china's
southern yunnan province this week
15 wild elephants including three calves
have trekked more than 400 kilometers
north from their habitat on the border
with myanmar and are now
outside the city of kunming their
journey has been monitored by millions
of people online
but they haven't been welcomed by all
farmer gorju guang was woken up after
midnight on wednesday
by the elephants forcing their way into
his courtyard
he climbed onto his roof for safety as
they ate his stores of corn
i was so scared the local government
want me to leave
but i didn't expect the elephants could
actually break into my house
so i chose to stay at home it was a
mistake
but the damage didn't end there the
elephants also trampled over his rice
fields
and smashed his fence officials say the
herd has so far destroyed more than a
million dollars worth of property
this is the closest that we could get to
the elephants
local authorities have set up these
checkpoints on the roads
leading up to where the herd are
currently traveling hundreds of police
have been deployed to keep onlookers
away
they're concerned that crowds getting
too close to the elephants
could pose a threat to both the animals
and the people
in recent years several farmers have
been killed in encounters with elephants
the animals commonly stray from their
home in shishwang banao reserve
china's biggest rainforest but
conservationists say
it's the first time a herd has traveled
this far
the main driver is the uh decrease and
fragmentation of the natural forest
that they live that they live with and
the
and the reason for the uh decreasing
and fragmentation of the nature forest
is because the
expansion expansion of human activities
such as a plantation
for example a tea and rubber trees and
also some
construction programs the forest area is
shrinking
and the number of elephants rising an
estimated 300
now live in this region authorities are
trying to encourage the family of
elephants to return home
by blocking roads and luring them south
with truckloads of food
but they're not expecting results
overnight more likely they say
it'll be slow and steady katrina you
al jazeera yunnan china